Do you subscribe to a magazine?
What was the last magazine you read?
Well, I always see you carrying around "Time" magazine,...
...and it seems like you are interested in news magazines.
What do you like about them?
I mean no offense here, but most women at your age, tend to read a lot of fashion or food magazines,...
..not magazines on current events.
Well, I'm a long time subscriber.
I have been a subscriber to "Time" for over, let me count the days, 15 years now.
I love reading those opinion - based news articles,...
...and that's why I choose to read "Time" magazine.
These days, you can basically read almost all magazine articles on the Internet,...
...in fact, a variety of articles.
But I like hard copies, because I can keep them for a longer period of time,...
...and I can always refer back to them.
Plus, I do love reading,...
...well I should say, "looking" at those fashion magazines, but I feel like it's a waste of money.
Fashion magazines are always up-to-date and therefore change so quickly.
So, there's no need to buy one, I see.
I used to like reading consumer car magazines or travel magazines,...
...but now I can find more information, pictures from the web, and also other people's comments.